what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time
well she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here not here actually but she's
here on the screen
with paulina yvette liva marinova
pompliano aka
my wife what's up what's up
it looks like you got on a prison outfit
with the stripes going on
outfit maybe sailor outfits a better
description we had technical
difficulties this morning there was
power outages
there was trees falling it was just a
horrible horrible city
yeah for her i just got out of bed and i
did some work but
my life is easy uh she's the one who had
the natural disaster
going on but she's you know right
what i'm saying are you safe okay cool
don't forget that lunch money is not
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can deposit crypto and take
out a us dollar loan and get your crypto
collateral or three you can earn up to
8.6
apy in an interest bearing account i'm
an investor i sit on the board i'm a
user i'm very happy you will be happy as
well
if you go and get a block fi account go
get a damn
account 8.6 apy it is a
no-brainer do your own research
and go get a wi-fi account blackfy.com
let's do it ready i'm ready i was born
ready
the us economy in the summer recovered
much of the historically enormous ground
it lost in the spring
expanding at the fastest rate on record
in the third quarter still the recovery
remains incomplete
so you know we were all expecting that
there would be great this crazy
recession slash depression
as a result of covet but you haven't
quite experienced it yet why not
ye i don't know if you could say that oh
really
well there's a couple of different ways
to look at it so
unemployment accelerated faster
right than uh it ever did in the great
depression
uh if you look at huh
but the recovery the third quarter was
one of one for the record books
the recovery is what people are looking
at is in things like
uh the stock market but if you still
look unemployment is still incredibly
high i think
unemployment remember correct is over
eight percent still right and so in
the first year of the great uh
depression uh we went from about three
percent unemployment
to uh eight point five or eight point
six percent unemployment in 1929
and then all of a sudden it went to 15
in
uh 1930. and so if you think about that
first you're like wait a second here
we actually are have more unemployment
now than we had
in the first year of the great
depression so i think like that's like
one of the stats another thing is
what percentage of small businesses end
up shutting down so it's great that
stocks have
uh recovered right and there's quote
unquote gdp growth
but that gdp growth is based on
the increase percentage so if it drops a
bunch and then it recovers some like of
course right it's kind of like the stock
market was like oh it's
up 50 off the bottom yeah but it's flat
year-to-date
right and so it's all about kind of what
happened before and so
again i do think that there's absolutely
a quote-unquote recovery happening right
there's
stores being open there's restaurants
being open all that kind of stuff um but
it's just nowhere near
what we need it to be um and so there's
still a lot of
you know damage uh that occurred there's
a lot of kind of obstacles in the future
and i think the scariest part is who
knows if this
uh siemens package is gonna get passed
like there's a lot of people who are
counting on that you know 1.82 trillion
dollars whatever it ends up being
a lot of people need that and uh
unfortunately you just got two sides
that are
they're standing like the okay corral 12
noon let's sit there draw
and they're just staring at each other
um and so we got to get something done
yeah well speaking of that the european
central bank
hinted at more monetary stimulus on
thursday as the two largest economies in
the region prepare for a second
national lockdown so a bunch of the
countries in europe are now doing a
complete lockdown for the second time um
so
the ecb is basically saying we're gonna
you know we're gonna
issue more stimulus to help people in
december
uh but this is gonna be bad do you think
the us is headed in that direction as
well
well we definitely are going to have
more stimulus it's just what's the
amount when does it get done right but
but for sure both sides want to get
stimulus done so i think something will
get done
the ecb um you know kind of central
banks around the world
it's just again the economies are
addicted to stimulus
they have to keep injecting liquidity
into the markets or you're going to see
i mean look what's happened over the
last couple of days in the u.s stock
market stocks all of a sudden they start
selling off
some of that is corona virus fear some
of that is political
just chaos um but a lot of it also is
the fact that look there's not liquidity
coming into the market
and therefore people are scared and so i
think that you're just gonna see the
same thing
play out in economies all around the
world and central banks all are in the
same boat if they have to
continue to stimulate the economy by
injecting liquidity
what do you think i'm just sad about it
i feel like you know banks
are getting you know they'll be fine but
the regular people
not sure i agree we'll see
all right let me sad no don't be sad
all right what's next i have a great
joke for you today though
but we'll we'll wait tik tock and its
chinese parent
by dance filed a case in san francisco
federal court
in response to a patent infringement
lawsuit that triller filed in july so
basically triller
filed a lawsuit in july claiming that
tick tock invite dance had been
infringing on its patents and stealing
its technology for years
now tick tock and by dance are arguing
that trollers allegations
have cast the cloud over by dance's
business
it's all political or uh legal posturing
really
yeah i mean basically it's like in any
legal fight right you just bring as many
bazookas to the table as possible and
you keep saying i'm gonna fire it i'm
gonna fire it
and then you start firing your bazookas
but i mean look at the end of the day
uh the market's going to decide which
one of these companies is the winner
and it's pretty clear that the market
has decided that tick tock
is the winner um sure triller has the
ability to raise capital
triller can try to kind of grow but i
find it
very hard to kind of
think about a world where triller ends
up taking down tick-tock
tick-tock goes away and triller's the
winner so maybe it could happen
it's just very very unlikely that that's
going to occur and i don't think that
this legal fight's going to have any
ramifications on
either one of the company's ability to
to acquire users
i agree okay controller i know you've
got a tick tock account you got a
trailer account
i do not i'm all tick-tock all right
i got neither go ahead okay spotify
is reaping the financial rewards of
betting on the podcasts
and the company on thursday said that
the joe rogan experience is now the
number one show in its english-speaking
markets
and it outperformed our audience
expectations after the podcast was added
to spotify september 1st
spotify also said the michelle obama
podcast was the number one show on its
platform globally in july and
august wow
yeah i don't i don't i don't want to
have to go down this path but i'm going
to go down this path
what what's the point is the latest
victim
of all this censorship nonsense what is
going on at spotify right now yeah it's
opened itself to
some controversy is absolute
nightmare and what i want to hear
is the leadership at spotify comment on
it
be a leader come out and say what do you
believe
do you believe that there should be
editorial control or not
but for some reason with all the social
media platforms everyone's
wants to hear from jack dorsey mark
zuckerberg you know
uh sundar piche right like all these
people
where's daniel eck yeah well i
i don't think daniel has really
commented has he no but what happened
yesterday
is a prime example so for those that
aren't paying attention
joe rogan did an episode with alex jones
and tom dillon
now before everyone freaks out joe rogan
is no idiot he knows exactly what he's
doing
so what he did is he recorded the
episode and he said
throughout the entire episode stop yeah
and they
immediately fact check right they would
go on and say is that true or is that
not it was topic by topic by topic
if you listen to the episode it's
actually annoying because it breaks up
the flow of the conversation to the
point where you're like dude this is so
ridiculous
i need to check this out but what joe
rogan was doing was he knew that they
were gonna come for him
right like them being the mob and so he
literally every single step along the
way
there's two main takeaways from the fact
checking that was going on and now
i use fact checking as like a mechanism
yes it's not the new york times fact
checking right it's
literally they're googling things but
still it was trying to identify what is
true what is not
one it was scary how much alex jones was
saying
and was correct was right because
they're literally sitting there googling
and that's not the narrative
publicly but if you listen to the
episode and you hear he'll say something
you're like that's ridiculous
and then they go to google like whoa
that's true i didn't know that
hardly breaking down the podcast they're
just saying hold on one second alex
jones let us go check this
literally out he'll be going crazy
saying all this stuff and joe wrote like
stop and then they go and they google it
right there on the spot
because they know that people were going
to come for them right and so it was a
way to kind of show and they call them
something like that's not true right
like what you just is not true
and i watched the kanye west episode of
joe rogan and he did a pretty good job
pushing back on
kanye's conspiracies of course so that's
the first thing
the second thing is yesterday
the episode was taken down from the
spotify
uh platform so all of a sudden it
disappeared from the feed
and everyone started tweeting about it
tweeting about it tweeting about
tweeting about it
i tweeted about it and all i said was
joe rogan interviewed alex jones they
fact checked the entire thing throughout
the conversation in real time
spotify took it down the people who are
encouraging censorship
love it until it happens to them right
so censorship
is always it it people are like oh it's
great that you know take down this
person i don't agree with
but what happens when the platform
doesn't agree with you right then you
don't like censorship
it's everyone's freaking out because the
episode got put back up
oh and the and spotify said to joe rogan
oh it was a caching issue
yeah i don't know it's all here's all i
want to say
there is no way that no episodes before
had caching issues
in the episode after the alex jones
uh episode had no caching issue so only
the one
controversial episode had a caching
issue
come on if you believe that as i've been
saying on twitter all morning
you're as gullible as the people who
believe the cdc when they said maths
don't work
but i don't think it's i don't think
it's a i don't think it's a
content issue i think it's more of like
a hate speech
is what they were arguing it violates
the hate speech policy
that they have as a as a company
understand
but that was the whole thing was i don't
think that there was any of that in
there
i haven't finished the whole thing so i
don't know for sure but based on what
i've seen from the reviews of the
episode
because they were fact checking every
single thing right
it wasn't just somebody spewing all the
nonsense and again i don't care
about alex jones or who the guest is the
point being that
the platforms should not be responsible
for editorializing
what the content is that's it go ahead
i'm done
got it a whopping 14 million to 23
million americans are planning to
relocate to a new u.s city or region
doing part of the growing acceptance of
remote work
wow that's a lot of americans i
personally anecdotally know a lot of
people who are actually moving
uh to other countries to other cities
yeah where are they moving like somebody
i just saw
that she's moving to london
should we move to london no we're good
but what do you think
we have friends who went to austin we
know
we go to austin huh should we move to
austin
no we're good for now right now we're
just going to stay in new york
right now we're good all right my boss
said i'm gonna stay in new york no
problem
all right ready yep final topic
before my joke okay the boston marathon
has postponed until at least the fall of
2020.
so it's normally in february i believe
or sorry in april
uh it's in april but they have postponed
it already for 2021.
and so it's the fall of 2012 oh fall of
2021
so basically they're not going to do it
in the spring next year they're going to
do it in the
fall yeah i mean
what do you kind of expect though right
at this point like they kind of don't
have an option
is my guess um okay
so um can i can i make you a bet
sure that this joke will get is
guaranteed to make you laugh
ready i wanna take this back this this
joe comes from
lunch money viewer named eva it is
why were the middle ages called the dark
ages
why were the middle ages called dark
ages yeah
i know eva so like i'm gonna laugh
anyways but go ahead
um because there were too many knights
get it
[Applause]
all right i don't know if the joke made
me laugh or evo made me laugh
for those that don't know queen is
everything is good all right you got to
be careful with that sword you can hurt
somebody
how jealous are you of that sword should
you steal love
yeah i kind of feel like polina should
bring that sword to new york let's see
you know
walk down the street see what happened
with that
are you guys having fun yeah it's great
all right maybe i'll come next time
okay cool i see everyone look at evo evo
has on a profile shirt look at that
[Music]
all right all right that's it for lunch
money today guys have a great day
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends